does that make you sad the future
where agi super intelligent or just
mediocre intelligent ai systems outlive
humans yeah i guess it depends on the
circumstances in which they outlive
humans so let's take the example that
you just gave
we send out you know very sophisticated
agis
on simple rocket ships relatively simple
ones
that don't have to have all the life
support necessary for humans and
therefore
they're of trivial mass compared to a
crude ship
a generation ship and therefore they're
way more likely to happen so let's use
that example
and let's say that they travel to
distant planets at
you know a speed that's not much faster
than what a chemical rocket can achieve
and so it's inevitably tens hundreds of
thousands of years before they make
landfall someplace
so let's imagine that's going on and
meanwhile
we die for reasons that have nothing to
do with those agis
diffusing throughout the solar system
whether it's through climate change
nuclear war
you know syn bio rogue symbiote whatever
in that kind of scenario the notion of
the agis that we created outlasting this
is very reassuring because it says that
like
we we ended but our descendants
are out there and hopefully some of them
make landfall and create some echo of
who we are so that's a very optimistic
one
where is the terminator scenario of a
super agi
arising on earth and getting left let
out of its box
due to some booboo on the part of its
creators who do not have super
intelligence
and then deciding that for whatever
reason it doesn't have any need for us
to be around and exterminating us
that makes me feel crushingly sad i mean
look i was sad
when my elementary school was shut down
and bulldozed
even though i hadn't been a student
there for decades yeah you know
the thought of my hometown getting
disbanded
is even worse that's the thought of my
home state of connecticut getting
disbanded and like
absorbed into massachusetts is even
worse the notion of
humanity is just crushingly crushingly
sad to me so you you hate goodbyes
certain goodbyes yes some goodbyes are
really really liberating but yes
well but what if the terminators um
you know have consciousness and enjoy
the hell out of life as well they're
just better at it
yeah well the have consciousness is a
really key element
and so there's no reason to be certain
that a super intelligence would have
consciousness
we don't know that factually at all and
so what is a very lonely outcome to me
is the rise of a super intelligence that
has a certain optimization function
that it's either been programmed with or
that arises in an emergently
that says hey i want to do this thing
for which humans are either an
unacceptable risk their presence is
either an unacceptable risk or they're
just collateral damage
but there is no consciousness there then
the idea of the light of consciousness
being snuffed out by something that is
very competent
but has no consciousness is really
really sad
yeah but i tend to believe that it's
almost impossible to create a super
intelligent agent that can't destroy
human civilization without it being
conscious
it's like those are coupled like you
have to in order to destroy humans
or supersede humans you really have to
be accepted by humans i think this idea
that you can build systems
that that destroy human civilization
without them being deeply integrated
into human civilization is impossible
and for them to be integrated
they have to be human-like not just in
body and form but
in in all the things that we value as
humans one of which is consciousness
the other one is just ability to
communicate the other one is poetry
music and beauty and all those things
like they have to be all of those things
i mean this is what i think about it it
does make me sad but
it's it's letting go which is uh
they might be just better at everything
we appreciate us
and that's sad and and hopefully they'll
keep us around but
i think it's a kind of
it is a kind of goodbye to uh
like realizing that we're not the most
special species on earth anymore
that's still painful it's still painful
and in terms of whether
such a creation would have to be
conscious let's say
i'm not so sure i mean you know let's
imagine
something that can pass the turing test
you know that something that passes the
turing test could
over text-based interaction in any event
um successfully mimic uh you know a very
conscious intelligence on the other end
but just be
completely unconscious so that's a
possibility
and that if you take that up a radical
step which i think we
can be permitted if we're thinking about
super intelligence
you could have something that could
reason its way through
this is my optimization function and in
order to get
to it i've got to deal with these messy
somewhat illogical things that are as
intelligent in relation to me
as they are intelligent relation to ants
i can
trick them manipulate them whatever and
i know the resources i need i know this
i need this amount of power
i need to seize control of these
manufacturing resources
that are robotically operated i need to
improve those robots with software
upgrades and then ultimately mechanical
upgrades
which i can affect through x y and z
that doesn't you know
that could still be a thing that passes
the turing test
i don't think it's necessarily certain
that
that optimization function mass
you know um maximizing entity
would be conscious see i so this is from
a very engineering perspective because i
i think a lot about natural language
processing all those kind of from
so very i'm speaking to a very specific
problem
of just say the turing test i really
think that
something like consciousness is required
when you say reasoning you're separating
that from consciousness but i think
consciousness is part of reasoning in in
the sense that
you will not be able to become super
intelligent
in the way that it's required to be part
of human society
without having consciousness like i i
really think it's impossible to separate
the consciousness thing
but it's hard to define consciousness
when you just use that word
sure even just like the capacity the way
i think about
consciousness is the important
symptoms or maybe consequences of
consciousness one of which is
the capacity to suffer i think ai will
need to be able to suffer
in order to become super intelligent to
feel the pain
the uncertainty the doubt the other part
of that is not just the suffering
but the con the ability to understand
that it too is mortal in in a sense that
has a self-awareness about his presence
in the world
understand that it's finite and be
terrified
of that finiteness i personally think
that's the fundamental part of the human
condition is this
fear of death that most of us construct
an illusion around but
i think ai would need to be able to
really
have it part of its whole essence
like every computation every part of the
thing that generates
that does both the perception and
generates the behavior
will have to have i don't know how this
is accomplished
but it i believe it has to truly be
terrified of death
truly have the capacity to suffer and
from that
something that would be recognized to us
humans as consciousness would emerge
whether it's the illusion of
consciousness i don't know the point is
it looks a whole hell of a lot like
consciousness to us humans
and i believe the ai when you ask
it will also say that it is conscious
you know in the full sense that we say
that we're conscious
and all of that i think is fully
integrated like you can't separate the
two the
idea of the paperclip maximizer
that sort of ultra rationally would be
able to destroy all humans
because it's really good at that at
accomplishing
the um a simple objective function
that doesn't care about the value of
humans it may be possible but the number
of trajectories to that
are far outnumbered by the trajectories
that create something that is conscious
something that
appreciative of beauty creates beautiful
things in the same way that humans can
create beautiful things
and ultimately like the the sad
destructive path for that ai would look
a lot like just better humans
than uh than like these cold machines
and i would say of course the cold
machines that
lack consciousness does the the
philosophical zombies
make me sad but also what makes me sad
is just
things that are far more powerful and
smart
and uh creative than us too because then
then in the same way that alpha zero
becoming a better chess player than the
best of humans
even starting with deep blue but really
with alpha zero
that makes me sad too one of the most
beautiful games
that humans ever created uh
that used to be seen as demonstrations
of the intellect which is chess
and go in other parts of the world have
been solved by ai that that makes me
quite sad
and it feels like the progress of that
is just pushing on forward oh it makes
me sad too
and to be perfectly clear i absolutely
believe that artificial consciousness
is entirely possible and that's not
something i rule out at all i mean you
if you
could get smart enough to have a perfect
map
of the neural structure and the neural
states and the amount of
neurotransmitters that are going between
every synapse in a particular person's
mind
could you replicate that in silica at
some
you know reasonably distant you know
point in the future absolutely and then
you'd have a consciousness i don't
rule out the possibility of artificial
consciousness in any way
what i'm less certain about is whether
consciousness
is a requirement for superintelligence
pursuing a maximizing function of some
sort
um i don't i don't feel the certitude
that consciousness simply must be part
of that
um you had said you know for it to
coexist with human society
would need to be consciousness could be
entirely true but it also could just
exist orthogonally to human society and
it could also
upon attaining a super intelligence with
a maximizing function
very very very rapidly because of the
speed at which computing works compared
to our own
you know meat based minds very very
rapidly
make the decisions and calculations
necessary to seize the reigns of power
before we even know what's going on
yeah i mean kind of like biological
viruses do yeah don't necessarily
they they integrate themselves just fine
with human society
yeah without but technically without
consciousness
without even being alive you know
technically by the standards of a lot of
biologists
you